[Applause]
homemade
shields against an army
the definition of an unfair fight
and someone else is about to
[Music]
a die has hit luin
his friends tried to drag him to safety
[Music]
he's 33 the eldest of three children
with everything to live for
[Applause]
but the generals waging war on the
people don't care
17 other protesters will be murdered
before the day is over
luin's friends desperately tried to
revive him
to save his life but the round
pierced his chest he didn't have a
chance
he's dead his sister cries
his mother sent her husband here to
collect her injured son
instead they're bringing home a body
his comrades come to pay their respects
the uprising must succeed they shout
they'll fight on in lewin's memory
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok